is this question of scientific literacy
in the United States is in fact one of
our greatest challenges what we
scientists would want people to
understand is a our science is not a
challenge to their religion because
that's the tension that we can see
rising in our society you'll remember
earlier I talked about the fact that we
build theories we don't build truths as
I understand religions they're about
truths that's a different thing and in
fact it's that wall that actually
protects religion from science and
vice-versa the fact that they're really
about very different things Stephen Jay
Gould used to call them non-overlapping
magisteria and I think that's about
right
even Galileo this makes this comment
about the different spheres in which
these two activities reside so I think
that's of great importance to us because
we know from looking at several thousand
years of history that when religion and
science clash science generally loses
for example over two thousand years ago
there were two philosophers named
Aristotle thought the knees and
Aristarchus who figured out that the
earth was round this belief was in
conflict with beliefs about the Olympian
gods and so this scientific fact was
lost until it was rediscovered with
Comper nika's about eighteen hundred
years later so the religion there wasn't
our one of our modern religions but it
was a religion and there are other
examples the first person who had the
idea that there might be life on another
planet was a priest by the name of
Giordano Bruno he paid in part for this
with his life so science loses when a
society sees science and conflict with a
religion we could do other examples so
that's one thing the other thing that we
would want people to know about is that
science is a process by which we are
trying to
decrease our ignorance we want to know
more about the universe we want to know
it more accurately and the ultimate
purpose of this knowing is to increase
the storehouse of human knowledge which
is ultimate to be used to increase the
quality of human life I think most of us
who do science would not do this if
someone said you can learn all these
things but at the end of the day it's
not for increasing everyone's quality of
life so I would personally want a
scientifically literate citizen to
understand that you're that scientists
are people that are really working on
behalf of not perhaps you but that would
be nice but maybe it's your children or
your grandchildren or your great-great
grandchildren or your great-great-great
great-great great-great
great-great-great grandchildren that in
fact it's a it's a commitment to
humanity and then I guess the final
thing that I'd like for the
scientifically literate citizen to do is
to be a lifelong learner to not
disengage because most people disengage
from science after they leave University
because it's not relevant to their life
they're doing something else making
money making a life but we're now moving
into a period in the history of our
nation where for example we have genomic
science I like to challenge people to
say look suppose you could have a
daughter that played tennis like Venus
Williams and looked like corner
Kournikova and played golf like Tiger
Woods would you choose not to give her
that opportunity or the genomic science
that may not become a theoretical
question and so we're gonna have to make
clever choices as a society about the
way we apply science genomic science
nanoscience you know I walk around
normally hooked up to a cell phone i I
see right now you have these plugs in
your ears listening a lot of us are
really plugged in well imagine that you
had a genomic device a rather nano scale
device
but you could surgically implant in your
brain that will allow you to directly
access the web don't you make that
decision well you might think that would
be really convenient to you remember
there are hackers out there do you want
people hacking in your brain so they're
really some great challenges science is
really putting us into the position of
defining redefining what it means to be
human but if that's going on we had
better have as broad a discussion as
possible in our society about what it is
that we want this will not happen if the
general public disengaged